sometimes that one relationship with an
agent that's all you need some people
don't realize that you're just one yes
away
from being completely financially free
making a difference yeah one yes well
thanks for coming to my house massive
congratulations on what you've built up
with your rent to rent business why
don't you start by just sort of telling
me what's your background and what was
it that made you want to get into
property how did you guys make it well
basically starting with myself i worked
as a quantity survivor for construction
company for seven years plus
we met in one of your advanced trainings
back november and since then we met for
a coffee and just clicked we had same
goals and we wanted to work on the same
strategy
and yeah and we found our first deal
after two weeks
amazing yeah and what was it that made
you think that because you know why did
you team up i think what made you think
that you'd work better as a partnership
well for myself i hadn't been on the
academy for long
i i didn't have the the funds behind me
so i was sort of trying to get into the
deal selling side of it
wasn't having much joy at the time and
we kept in touch after the after the
deal selling yeah and uh decided to
message him on instagram saying oh
because he went for a fishing um yeah
yeah they only wanted to come fishing
but we still haven't got to go yeah yeah
we've been too busy now oh then you're
probably business yeah
when did you quit your full-time jobs
and go full time in property
so for you you'd already
i did it when i joined academy october
because i just wanted to put skin in the
game commit fully and i had some savings
so i knew what my goal is big risk
though isn't it quitting your a good job
as a surveyor yeah and just saying i'm
going to be a full-time property
investor entrepreneur that's true i
remember that happening now and i
remember you telling me at the time um
so okay what's your background then jack
so i've worked for my dad ever since we
left school
on commercial bodies we build lorry
bodies um
done that for 18 years
um
hated it for the whole duration but it
was
just a case of not having the courage or
the education to go and do what i wanted
to do
so
i was just living for the week and going
around in circles for for too many years
yeah um
and then and then it just it got too
much in the end and i finally decided i
need to do something about it
so i found you on uh instagram um
was following you on there
um didn't take much notice at first but
then as as time went on and i realized i
wanted to sort myself out i
i kind of i decided that i'd sign up to
the crash course and see what it's all
about um
i actually looked online to see where
where the next one was and it actually
was in my hometown in two weeks time
in chelmsford so i thought it's gotta be
it's gotta be now or never so yeah took
the plunge and haven't looked back since
when you say you ignored it at first saw
instagram and you what did you mean by
that well i started because i i was
interested in property um but i was
under the illusion like many that you
need loads of money to invest in
property so
i always had an interest in it so i
started following you but i wasn't
um interested or educated enough to sort
of follow up on it yeah but your
presence on instagram was always there
so
it got to a point where i started
saving up some money
and started sort of taking more notice
of of the property game
and then i decided to
to
sort of follow you more
and then
signed up to the crash course and that
was that how much did you hate your job
well obviously obviously not enough to
to sort of take action for 18 years
what was it feel like though what did it
feel like waking up and going to a job
that you didn't enjoy every day for 18
years
it's difficult but i'm a very motivated
person i don't struggle to get out of
bed
no matter what i've got to do i can get
out of bed
so
i
it was difficult but um
i was working for my dad so i kind of
put pressure on myself
that i kind of should be there
i kind of put unnecessary pressure on
myself that i was supposed to be there
helping the family business um but dad
always supported me to go and do doing
my own thing
um
but i was just stuck in this vicious
circle living for the weekend yeah you
know the usual stuff a lot of people do
that until they're 67. and then they
realize they've wasted the whole left
leg what did you enjoy your job damian i
do i do
my my story was i actually i wanted to
do a part-time job i i asked my boss
because i wanted to just
do something about properties i did
enroll to your academy um
course first and that was for a while
but to be honest i was so busy at work i
didn't have i didn't pay attention to
courses so i said it's either or so i i
had to commit and i knew i need to put
skin into the game
and then
gradually just picking up on the old
strategies and i remember um when was
actually it was one of your advanced
training on the developments as well
because
my dream is you know get into
developments later on yeah and i
enrolled academy and said no that that's
got to be done now i've got some savings
so
uh i know what i've got to do yeah and
and then since then i just yeah just
so since then you know you guys have
really dominated on the rent to rent
space which we'll talk about and i know
you're making very good money um from
from your properties which you don't own
you control them yeah and you've got
properties where about watford so
watford colchester and we've just taken
on two more in cambridge amazing
cambridge is a really nice area yeah
yeah
we're a lot like actually i live 20
minutes away from cambridge yeah jackie
said just about to move into cambridge
um so yeah that that's going to be our
probably
pass
i'd love to talk about how you've done
that the struggles the lessons and so
people were watching this yeah the same
thing it's also interesting that you
decided to go all or nothing and
everyone's wired differently a lot of
people on the academy do the property
business on top of their job don't they
but some people do choose to just go
full time when did you register jack
when did you register for the academy um
on the deal selling master class um i'd
been
been there for the
two days of the four yeah
i had the money saved up and i was
loving the environment and i knew that
if i wanted to pursue my property
journey it was the right right place to
be it's worked out all right yeah it's
doing quite well so far
so tell me about your first deal and how
it was structured and how you found it
and what happened so the first deal was
direct from landlord we found this on
guntree
and called the landlord a conversation
built the report
we went for a viewing actually i went
for myself because jack wasn't available
um
and then
and john the landlord was so pleased
about what i've told him about how he's
going to be structured
about um we're going to take on the
management uh full control paying him a
guaranteed fixed rent long-term contract
maintenance on us uh yeah and then we
had another viewing yeah a couple days
later yeah it was while we were
negotiating then we went both and we
negotiated
a deal we dropped on a
rent we managed to
secure grace period of three weeks
what for and then after again after a
couple of days we signed a contract so
it was very fast of course actually this
one was and where when you say you found
it on gum trays how did you even know
where to look in the first instance how
did what happened everything is um
from you actually we we've been taught
very well on a
academy or academy itself uh we
obviously go to live trainings so you
you teach was it on a training program
you found it or were you at home it was
it was literally um it was literally in
the cafe when we met first time no we
when we first met to have a catch up
yeah and decided that we were going to
try and find our first deal
yeah we actually done the call that day
yeah
so and what was the advert what was it a
house an apartment it was no pictures
whatsoever
uh
the lander thought i'm an agent he
didn't really want to speak to me but i
said no i'm not an agent and i just went
to see the property via the property
explained yeah a little bit more and
more details and yeah he was very and
this is what is it a house or an
apartment it's a free bed for a bit flat
flat on suit and whereabouts is it
waterford watford just outside so you
basically rang him up on gumtree had a
conversation told him that it would be a
company left yes you're not a management
company but you wanted to pay the rent
over a long term let and then you
arranged to have a viewing to discuss
that's great did you both go to the
viewing not the first time around i was
still working yeah were you hating your
job at this point like i need to leave
samia had to go on his own um obviously
done a good job yes then john the lion
how long did it take you to get the keys
in your hands
i think it since it was saturday and the
key was monday after not next monday
monday afternoon okay so like just over
a week yeah over a week yeah just over a
week and that property how much rent do
you pay
we pay 1250. 12.50 so 1250 pounds and
talk to me about what do you do with it
how do you make money
so we rent it as um service
accommodation
um
so
we obviously paid a 12.50 guaranteed a
rent and no maintenance or voids for
them
so then we're getting a nightly rate on
top
yeah turnover for this property is um
circa 4 thousand four thousand four
thousand yes for the one apartment as
well three businesses eighty percent
occupancy it's a wonderful location good
area lots of contractors coming in uh
you've got warner bros studio there so
it's buzzing how does the landlord feel
about that we've explained this this
strategy to them we're not the new
we're gonna go put that on airbnb why
doesn't the landlord just do that
himself because he's 83 years old now so
he's very happy just getting his rent
and when he gets the chance he wants to
go back to thailand and just live his
best life
yeah time poor uh no experience um
probably he skipped the training program
he skipped the training program yeah
because it is a business it's not about
i don't think it's as easy as just
sticking it on airbnb is it you've got
to have cleaner systems procedures
you've got to understand how to welcome
the guests
it's a business it's a business and it
takes time just to structure it and to
learn the process as you say even if you
found the property and you run this as a
service accommodations later on to
systemize and and find the right label
people like cleaners you mentioned
it's it's it's it's a challenge and
remember you coming on the mastermind
calls sort of saying like i can't find
cleaners or i got and 83 years old you
don't want that hassle and you've got
all the support and the power team and
all that so
yeah the contracts also a lot of people
aren't even sure about the compliance
the legislation so talk to me about that
like is this if this is an apartment is
there not a head lease restriction or do
you not need planning permission to do
this no see he he owns the whole block
so it was three flats and two shops
he actually lives next door to the one
we've taken on
um there's another one being renovated
downstairs isn't there that we're going
to be taking on as soon as it's finished
and then there's a
beauty salon and a flower shop
underneath yeah
so it's freehold it's house converted to
floods so there is no uh
nice place
now so what
what's your profit on that then if
you're generating four grand you have to
pay the landlord 1250 what kind of
profit are you left with with that first
deal in averages like between 1500 and
1700 right that's a full-time wage yeah
that's a full-time salary for a lot of
people yeah that's incredible yeah this
one it's just don't work really well how
did you feel when you saw the money
coming in and you wow just couldn't
believe it yes you have to punch
yourself
in the book especially when because and
we've got a really good tip for myself
when um one of mastermind is said do not
wait yeah do not wait on um until
you can because we've been refurbishing
this property so there was three
weeks period
um and we we put this on on airbnb and
booking.com and we didn't finish the
refurbished we had a 30 days booking
for his property he was advised by tony
to on the mastermind call to list the
property before it's ready yeah he said
just find
a picture of the front door if you have
to so i staged it with there was kind of
bits in there
and they left a bit of furniture in
there temporarily hadn't they so i
staged it the best i could took photos
yeah and we got a contractor booking for
a whole month that's
and that's a really good tip as well
because if you'd have waited until it
was all ready and then you put it on
then you're losing money then um how did
you negotiate to not pay any rent for
three weeks
we said because property in fair uh
required some light reverb so we painted
it
changed a few things painted some
furniture we explained how we're gonna
do that we're gonna bring the value to
the property
it takes time to obviously stage this um
and they they were happy about that they
gave us free so you got three months
sorry three weeks grace period did you
have a deposit no not on that one
so no deposit no rent and then you put
it on airbnb straight away before it's
even ready and start getting bookings
yeah
for the first rent to run it was perfect
yeah wasn't it
in fact in fact we yeah yeah that was
great we've got cambridge similar
situation we put that on airbnb before
finishing it
and yeah
another 30 days what would happen if the
landlord said i want my property back
in terms of contracts
we've got closes in there so he cannot
do that legally
so
we've got a close in the contract saying
that he's got to give us a
free three months rent back
if he's going to seize the contract
on because of i don't know his his will
so you've got it's
a contract do you think they're very
important to have the right contracts to
protect yourself essential yeah you've
got to have yourself covered and a lot
of people don't realize this do they
they just download contracts for free on
the internet or whatever and then they
end up losing their property or having
some issues yeah it's a big part having
the legally binding contracts obviously
that we get on the academy yeah we've
got a template which is very help yeah
so when did you then leave work so i i
was in the i was in the process of i had
a small business i had i had a mobile
bar business um which i was selling so i
could then have the money from that as a
cushion while we were sort of building
our income yeah it was between first and
second property remember yeah yeah so we
we got together in january so it must
have been mid-february i managed to sell
the bar right and that gave me that
cushion today yes to go full-time
yeah and then since then you got
obviously a lot more renter rents where
was your second one
colchester
and was that with the same landlord all
differently in different lands where did
it come from
country again country so gumtree's the
one then yeah gumtree's powerful yeah
gantry's powerful what's so good about
gumtree
you've got you've got leads uh it's a
number where you can call the landlord
and discuss
and tell them what you want to do if
they're properly they're happy to you
know give it to you people that don't
want to deal with agents really so they
just try and list it themselves yeah so
they're a lot more uh sort of
approachable and open to ideas and also
you're not having to have a gatekeeper
because normally if you if you ring
someone through rightmove you're
speaking to stacy who's 24 years old who
has all these systems and stuff in place
where she's
you know doesn't understand lease
options and rent events and it can be
much more tricky whereas when you're
talking to the decision maker the owner
yeah
how how difficult is it to become
compliant and regulated in this industry
it's not that easy to be honest i think
once you've got that knowledge and then
education you set up company
you've got insurances in place obviously
which covers you um and and and and
what you do
uh
and then
you just can go ahead with with finding
deals it's one of those things that you
only need to do once yeah once you've
done it you've done it once you've got
your insurance your company your
compliance your contracts you then can
go go and go again
what's your profit then at the moment
from your rent to rent how much are you
making after all your expenses your
utilities your landlord fees your
insurance what what sort of profit
you're making so we're averaging about
four and a half thousand at the minute
over the four properties that we've got
right
it's not bad
not bad at all have you got more
entrepreneurs in the pipeline we've got
a couple more in the parking lot we've
got our first landlord at watford
the one downstairs we're going to be
taking on as soon as that's finished
right um
we've got another one that's happy to
take take us on
um but they're just dragging their heels
a bit with a refurb on the on the
property we've also met yeah we've also
managed to build the airport with excuse
me uh estate agent electing agents
because our third property is from
lighting agent yeah and i believe
because they liked what we did and
they're going to give us some more that
is the advantage to letting agents yeah
if you get one deal from a random
landlord that owns one property that's
the end of it whereas if you get one
from a letting agent they'll usually
pass you more and more sometimes that
one relationship with an agent that's
all you need i've had people on windows
on a wednesday that have literally only
stripped one they've only had one yes
yeah they've had 100 no's and then one
yes and that's from from a letting agent
and then they're financially free that's
exactly
some people don't realize that you're
just one yes away
from being completely financially free
making a difference yeah one yes what's
been what's been the hardest um struggle
then was there was any time when you
felt like quitting or you thought
property or maybe this isn't as good as
it cracked up today
not not um i haven't thought that about
property but um the
approaching agents and landlords can be
difficult um cleaners has been difficult
that's what i was thinking of really
struggled to find reliable cleaning why
do you think it's so hard to find good
cleaners
every people got different standards
they work we we've got quite high
standards and because we run business
and we we want our sites to be high
standards we have to be yeah because
they're giving us um profit which we
want yes um
sometimes people we've got occasions
when people turn up they did job they
didn't turn up anymore without giving us
any reason why whatsoever and this is
we've we've had a couple that um have
just said that we need more of a maid
service they just they they weren't kind
of it's the making the beds it's it's
no you need to get them to be the host
as well don't you yeah we need them
looking out for me do you think one of
the reasons it might might have been a
little bit more difficult for you is
because you've got properties kind of
all over the place you've got different
areas
it could be because we've got
in each different area we've got
different cleaners in place so we don't
have one cleaner at all but it does make
it more difficult liaising when we've
got them spread out
how's life how's life changed then as a
result of property
um
life's changed a lot because i
i worked in a job that i hated for for
so long for 18 years and now i'm getting
out of bed to a job that i'm really
excited to to start the day
yeah so it's changed a lot for me
personally is it more of a lot more
freedom would you say yeah yeah i was
going to say that freedom independence
and being your own boss
we've got strong work ethic and same
attitude and what jack says i i i
understand this because
wake up early and know what you're doing
have a plan and that vision just you
building on your empire or your
portfolio knowing that you've got your
rent rent now strategy but you've got so
many other strategies you want to do
yeah and it's it's crazy it's that's
what drives me it's incredible yeah how
do you know when a what a deal is good
or bad how do you know when you see a
property right this is going to work
space
when we do due diligence we obviously
compare with
other properties other essays on
bookings and airbnb
we
approach hotels asking them
basically taking a look on the area if
the area is good for contractors um i
don't know um businesses
it's if it's buzzing or not and um and
then we just um doing your numbers doing
your numbers yeah yeah
have you had to walk away from deals
we did we've we've had quite a few um
we had a period of three months where we
had no deals but we was kind of
negotiating quite a few one in hartford
we've had two on the line yeah he was
negotiating a few and that relationship
just wasn't there
yeah it wasn't stacking they were asking
for too much yeah what was that oh jimmy
yeah yeah how do you get through like
when you quit your job because you both
quit your job really early how do you
get past the referencing stage of things
it was thankfully we had this one from
the landlord direct they didn't ask for
references i.e like um so they gave you
a hold on so they gave you the keys to a
property
zero deposit
no rent for three weeks grace period and
they didn't even ask you for references
third one they've asked and four or four
yes the thing is the first one is the
hardest because once you've got the
first one you can use that as a
reference yeah so you can say oh speak
to this dude that's what we did we've
just done that to get our one in
cambridge do you think you've got to
look at it or do you think you've just
had to work hard i think we work hard
work basically
and you've invested thousands of pounds
into training you're crazy people can
say you do create your own luck people
can say you got lucky but
yeah i mean you wouldn't have you
probably wouldn't have gone all in as
well because uh people um often ask me
you know why is your mentorship so
expensive was it thousands and thousands
of pounds um i personally think it's
quite cheap for you to get but if it
wasn't thousands of pounds if it was
just a couple hundred quid people would
register and then they wouldn't do
anything you know you've heard me say
this before but if you want to do
anything professionally you always get
trained to get a coach get educated and
probably i don't think it's any
different it's a business isn't it and
if you you know if you want to succeed
in the business um it makes sense to put
a little bit into yourself before then
going full steam ahead because if you
lost just what that first deal just that
one deal alone yeah over the six 12
months he's gonna pay back all the
training and some and then you've got
all the other deals on top yeah and
people you you get known they're an
environment we just every monday we've
got masterminds we listen to
successes we listen to stories they
struggle with
it's building on us as well
we want to be inspirational we want to
be we want to be helping people as well
that's our
myself and jack this someone
as well
what was it that made you
agree to come down and do this interview
it was like a phone call conversation
and i said yes
it was kind of we
it's important to us to celebrate your
achievements and we haven't had stopped
yet yeah yeah and we celebrated what
we've achieved yeah so for me it was
kind of um
a good time for us to to stop and sort
of recognize how far we've come in a
short space yeah yeah that's true i
didn't think about that it's like it's
because
we keep saying um after this one we'll
start we're going to have a day off work
we're not going to mention work and
we'll go and do what we want to do do
some fishing yeah
we haven't done it here when you when
you become multi-millionaires maybe
you'll take a day to go fishing well the
lake will be in the back garden
so what would you say your biggest
advice to somebody that's wanting to get
into this industry rent to rent
specifically
what would you say would be a good
starting point
myself is get education
take actions
surround yourself with like-minded
people
get that network around
being compliant is is very important
um
and again have this
determination just just never stop just
no matter what there's a way to just go
around this amazing that's great really
good summary of of some practical steps
there what about yourself
yeah it's just having that burning
desire to succeed
um just get immersed in the
environment and speak to people that are
achieving what you want to achieve
yeah
it's like i said earlier really it's
just
just immersing yourself around the right
people people around you that sort of
question what you're doing i've had that
a lot
but to be honest
everyone around me supports me they know
i'm going to go and do what i want to do
yeah and so they've all been pretty
encouraging what do they think when you
quit your job were they shocked um
they weren't shocked because they knew
that it was coming they they just didn't
know what it was that was going to sort
of
get me out of there well what yourself i
shot i've got family here um i i'm the
person
who actually wouldn't say something and
just promise myself i'm going to do that
i want to find a way to do this so when
i first thought about going to
full-time property
journey i sat down with my wife and
explained the situation so i said we've
got some savings should be all right
give us
give myself six months if this will not
work out i will always can come back to
work because quantity surveying is it's
quite good work it's decent salary and
you can find you can find this that's
really interesting yeah so you basically
did the what i teach which is best case
worst case yeah yeah worst cases you
know what i've lost six months i've made
some friends
didn't work back to my job best case is
what's happened pretty much yes which is
incredible yeah we did we did both have
that security of we could go back to our
yeah our old jobs yeah but um obviously
it still takes courage to sort of step
out and go for it and you can always get
a job again yeah yeah
exactly i i'm on the same page my
mindset is like that it just if there is
a will there is a way
um so you can what you talk about
burning desire where does that come from
what's your strongest reason for doing
this um my biggest reason why is
my dad has sacrificed a lot of family
time running his business
and um one christmas time he said to me
that his biggest regret was
um that he didn't spend enough time with
us as kids
um and i don't ever want to be in that
position if i'm fortunate enough to have
a family so
that stuck with me and kind of having
that freedom
um to to do what i want to do
um
is that's the biggest thing for me is
the freedom yeah set yourself up for
life yeah exactly he could be around
loved ones that's amazing what about
yourself damian family as well first
being independent
travel around the world
have that freedom
being your own boss
and and
constantly improving
you learn every day yeah um
yeah
what does your wife think of what you've
done oh she's she's amazed i think she's
so proud of myself like myself uh
yes we were very happy we're very happy
where we are now grateful
um just just yeah just go to the next
chapter well i have huge admiration for
you guys and i'm really pleased and
proud of what you've done
what's it been like working with me for
the last six months then amazing um you
just straight to the point as well so
you tell us what to do and give us a you
know kicking me out back side when i'm
providing that support providing our
support and always when we text you you
always come back with something
uh very useful and with the devices so
we thank you for that as well it's a
pleasure
and um thank you for coming on the
channel and inspiring people thank you
for having us yeah big respect keep on
going we'll do part two next year i'm
sure yeah
guys thank you
[Music]
you